mais a le plus tard
voilà ça
ouais
voilà tu vois toute la map
aulas
c'est pas la lys marqué spécifié waouh
à tuvalu j'aurais pas touche
ouh la la vie l'homme quasimodo ta
[ __ ]
wells en partir là bas
solutions réseau sauf à tous
[Musique]
jb je rentre
comme moi
ok live dans le groupe r d mais quand
manoir ailleurs donc ça aa
c'est quoi ça
ouah ça claque ce truc j'avais joué avec
sa main
à ces styles
je
bien gratuit vise la tête
ça va
c'est bien parti
ah je faire l'accolade
chose de potable
les dernières
bon j'étais président
waouh c'est bon c'est fini voilà
hu a failli
[Musique]
à part
genre tu changes d'armes nuisibles
on va prendre 20 km
non mais n'est ce pas là
corps de là bas mon sac
il crève faille sais pas pourquoi ils
tirent en l'air des points
waouh
il doit rester un ou deux là maximum
que tu m'aimes
prudent
c'est fait j'économise les balles va
constater je cherche peut-être
ted
d'accord
ça fait
à s
a cédé sens pourquoi s'explose pas
donc j'ai la place bonne grosse boîte de
schalk end à moi
c'est bien la ccir là dedans que ça
explose
je pense alors s'expliquer
ça c'est vrai
tu sais pas comment ils s'en sortir
c'est un peu toujours répétitif comme je
trouve que
tu fais un peu souvent pareil quoi tu
bourrine tube ou rien'
après il ya les cinématiques qui dure 1
minute et humoriste humour on vient du
travail et par là parfait fabien ne
serait pas venu à leurs besoins par si
le tient la chandelle
pourquoi ça a rien je trouve que ça va
est ce parce que c'est quoi ces deux
termes qui ne proposait pas juste 13 la
foulée sur un mec ivresse
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est des ennemis
ces bâtards bons je t'en veux pas je
trouvais pas
moi je stresse puisque avant lui
matar matar il a signé là là ta gueule
soirée j'ai bien vu en plus latchès
refusé de merde baisse de petipa tard
le titre
alors un choix peu austère
bon faut aller là où il ya les méchantes
manière
et ici c'est ce poète pour ces faits
peur vérifie aujourd'hui tu es là dedans
on ne voit pas les trucs roi du monde
excusez moi ni à ma mère alors qu'outre
mer à yport
à sept bandits des talents
parfait la table je pense pas retraités
[Musique]
ok wahba tard j'y crois pas
dégage
alors masqué pas malin et au mal
ce qui est faux liban
[Musique]
l'air comme ça on est bien découvert
dépasse à ce qu'on bat à
attends je suis sur lui alors voilà
je sais pas je tire sur lui et pas moi
ça va je recommence similaires c'est que
ça s'active bien en dessous des censeurs
à voir
bien manger de l'autre la balle à turin
alors leurs ouailles arleux ça c'est
fait
o sappey
des one shot
c'est bon ça l'arbre
et pour sortir après voilà votre avatar
dans le petit bâtard
ayes nettoie la mauricie
petit ya
j'évoquais avoir trop fait dans la demie
repérait alors on descend
face aux menaces tout
entre là dedans
pas rentrer c'est un mastodonte ou pas
j'ai constaté un mastodonte bats pas tu
as
je
ah j'ai vidé mon genre version
disponible
ok vite banques la partie tout mais qui
est plein drogue dans les favelas
là il va prendre pour toi ni de l'homme
souhaite enfin c'est fini la patrouille
de palme
alors là tu es trop la femme qui criait
c'est lé là je n'ai pas peur je suis pas
là pour te faire du mal non plus
ça c'est fait tu as pris tellement cher
je suis désolé navré navré pour taylor
n'avait pourtant pas l'état de la
chaussée moins cher mais plus forte
mortalité voir ici un groupe trop bien
faire
un chrono qui suit à faire
well as the c'est vrai que plus les
pièges du diable
[Musique]
c'est reparti pour être dans la merde je
fais ça je précise qu'en fait
parti
quand j'ai vu huy
est ce que je vais bien fait
bayard
falls et a désigné par tous là par
contre j'ai pas de réserves
voilà c'est super oh non mais pour
remercier personnellement de son en pâte
à tarte
[Applaudissements]
et voilà et je suis projeté là dedans
comme une grosse merde
à
rêve [ __ ] j'ai pris cher
la la c'est hardcore
alors c'est vrai que c est à chaque fois
j'ai
voilà la la la la la a list là il est
mort rappelons rien c'est bon
ces dames
waouh
là bas
cet hiver ah je sais
là on se met à couvert
parfait
si grave si je suis engagé
là où
à
ouais bah force est un peu coincé ces
débris dans quoi tu les vois pas assez
ou
ouaddou à des remplaçants
ça vient d'où ça vient de là
non mais techniquement je suis désolé
mais jamais jamais dans la vraie vie tu
gardes le bassin
non
c'est pas gâcher
explique hp pas le sillage du bétail
ok
au hockey
ouah
viser la roquette
ouais mais surexcitée mamans ont fait
descendre
voilà là mais cette mission malick fall
bandits qui sont pas bon ça en six
thématiques rien de rock et musique
ah non ils l'ont tué
[Musique]
non
lundi débuter et voilà chapitre vite les
gens j'espère que ces longs épisodes
vous plairont en tout cas on se retrouve
on essaie prochain preneur l'épisode je
serai au milieu corse surtout monde un
bateau pis